ladies and gentlemen your host for this
evening Academy Award winner Whoopi
Goldberg
ah oh who knew it was this hard to get a
virgin off your face
so I'm gonna throw this down here it'll
hit somebody by like right thank you
oh good evening and welcome Oscar is 71
honey so welcome to the early bird
special this is the biggest party in
Hollywood probably the second biggest if
you count the Democrats it is the last
it's alright take your time it's the
last Oscar show before the Millenium and
I get to host it so I am the last 20th
Century Fox
we're coming to live from Hollywood the
town that invented lying about sex you
know come on you know it's true last
time I did this I mentioned all the
ribbons people had asked me to wear for
all the different causes of course the
last time I was here the most
controversial thing you could put on a
dress was a ribbon what times change and
I feel I need to get all of this out of
my system right now so here goes
subpoenas cigars Black Parade
DNA interns rug burns henry hyde
gratified prime time confession jury
intention mr. trent lott out out damn
spot
a quiet immunity which is a deficient
syndrome talking points approval rating
phone sex dating stop hanging out and
betty curries driveway honey let that
[ __ ] get into her car
with a gentleman yields larry flynt bob
barr ken starr har-har-har 50 million
down the drainer for that kind of money
we could have made five good movies
which is what tonight is really all
about
yeah I got it out my system but I'm not
totally out of the woods I just want to
ask why is it every time I do this show
I get the year with the controversy
remember last time why did I get it this
time y2k forget it why to me I thought
the blacklist was me and had him
McDaniel [ __ ]
you spare me nothing you know who's
having the biggest year of all once
again Shakespeare honey Little Willie is
very large baby of course it was
Shakespeare in Love 13 nominations but
Shakespeare's influence was everywhere
and I think few people realize that the
hare scene and there's something about
Mary was lifted out of one of his early
plays no it's true
much nothing about her do
I'm sorry that's my favorite I would
guys want to know how come that Hindu
wasn't nominated for special effects you
really think anybody's gonna remake that
movie shot-for-shot life is so unfair I
mean Ben Stiller does that scene and
gets three million dollars George
Michael did it got arrested
of course it wasn't all love stories
this year there was also war and not
just the Ovid CA a thing they were then
about limits my time in Hollywood were
they also the Oscar campaigns mounted by
DreamWorks the mirror backs honey
those boys fought World War three over
World War two now for you young
Hollywood types who don't know what
World War two was it was the sequel to
World War one Americans spent more than
seven billion dollars this year to see
our movies that's as much as the average
olympic official takes home every week
it was also a very big year in animation
Computers help make bugs and ants
completely lifelike they couldn't do
jack for the House Judiciary Committee
but what do I know
no really I thought Hillary and Jackie
was about a support group for first
ladies Oh
you missing Billy just about now engine
the Billy's home honey his legs are
kicked up he's laughing at me some of
the best actors in the world were
nominated this year one or two of them
were even American but hey there's
Gwyneth Paltrow she played a woman who
wanted to be an actor so badly she
pretended she was a man mocking the only
time in movie history that a woman has
had her breasts reduced to get apart
there's Geoffrey Rush and Shakespeare in
Love hello Geoffrey he played a producer
with no money to pay the rider here we
call that an independent and there is
nothing like a dame you know that we got
Judge Judy tonight we got Dame Judi baby
Dame Judi Dench last year she played
Queen Victoria this year she played
Queen Elizabeth she's determined to play
every queen in England and let's see is
she doing Boy George
I could go on but our producer I won't
has come up with new and novel way of
letting people know that they've been on
too long if you step in one 30 seconds a
giant asteroid comes hurling at you from
the balcony
so Armageddon ready to hand out some
little belt
it was so good to me I said one more
time Armour getting ready to hand out
some little ball boys who knows which
way it will go Romeo
Roberto Ryan Thin Red Line big red wig
nobody knows honey